what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday
it's [__] memorial day who gives a
[__] what day it is
it's [__] memorial day and i'm
here to salute the troops
and thank you for your service and your
dedication to this great [__] country
of ours but
the joint is brought to you by magnesium
breakthrough tremendous take it from me
if you want to be healthy
you need a good night's sleep i've been
talking about that for [__] years
there's no substitute and i know it's
hard guys
between the sleep apnea the anxiety it's
a regular three-ring [__] circus for
me on some nights
but i've tried everything from tease to
[__] you know me
one thing that really helps me is
magnesium magnesium breakthrough has
taken me deep
into the waters of dreamland yeah i do
the michael jackson t
some nights and all that but magnesium
has been a steady with me
since before we [__] before the
surgery
magnesium is a tremendous mineral not
only does it help you with sleep
it reduces stress it helps you maintain
a regular heartbeat
it boosts your immunity it lowers
[__] cortisol which is important
and most people are magnesium deficient
even popeye can't eat enough [__]
spinach
to get enough magnesium breakthrough
works fast
just pop two capsules before you go to
bed in 30 minutes
you'll be sleeping like a [__] baby
do me a favor don't sleep on this offer
just for the church uh for the joint
family
go to magbreakthrough.com again
magbreakthrough.com
slash showy and use joey 10.
what i'm going to do for you is during
checkout you're going to save
10 percent magnesium breakthrough is a
full
spectrum it's the only organic
supplement that's
includes seven unique forms of magnesium
i've been sleeping better and i wake up
feeling tip-top magoo
plus i'm more relaxed and i'm at peace
throughout the day you guys can see that
in me yes i'm eating right and i'm going
to the gym and i'm
taking care of myself in other areas but
i can't [__] tell you enough
about magnesium breakthrough so do me a
favor
go to the magbreakthrough.com right now
use code joey during checkout
and i'm going to send you 10 [__]
percent and like metallica says
tell the sandman uncle joey sent you
[__]
the joint is also brought to you by
bluetooth oh [__] memorial means
memorial day means one thing stand
back and let that rocket [__] go off
somebody's sucking your [__] dick
this [__] weekend
you've been home for 15 [__] months
some of you
forgot how to date you forgot how to do
anything but blue chew is here
to light your [__] bedroom up so you
can light a little monkey on fire
you understand me blue chew is
tremendous it's an online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis
at a fraction of the cost and you can
take it anytime day and night
and it's simple you sign up at
bluetooth.com
again bluechew.com b-l-u-e-c-h-u-e-e-w
dot com and speak to one of our licensed
medical providers once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days the best part
it's all online no [__] dirty visits
to the doctor
no awkward conversations no eye beating
no waiting online at the pharmacy
it ships right to your door in a
discreet package the mailman
don't know dick if you could benefit
from extra confidence when it's time to
perform
blue chew can help even if you don't
have erectile dysfunction
you don't show up with a gun with five
bullets do you no you show up you want
[__] six bullets and you want two
bullets in your socks
just in case you gotta shoot your feet
anyway we got a special deal for you
try blue chew free joey
don't mess with me it's memorial day
blue chew for free
when you use promo code joey at checkout
just pay five dollars for shipping
that's bluechu.com code joey to receive
your first month free and as always i
want to thank bluechu
for sponsoring the joint and now
let's get this little party started all
right we got bluetooth
we got magnesium breakthrough and we got
you guys
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday
the last day of the month happy
memorial day to you [__] if
you're watching this podcast it's
because
nobody invited you to anything and uh
you're a [__] stiff like me
no it was a [__] up weekend i get it
it was a [__] up weekend but we made
it i'm happy it's memorial day happy
memorial day
to everybody who served and their
families uh you know i know that this is
what it's really all about
but it just was [__] what a hell of a
weekend i mean
listen jersey is great because during
the week it's 90 degrees and you're
jumping up and down but let me tell you
something
for years i've been monitoring the
weather
on the weekends in [__] jersey and
new york you know you talk to re
i talk to different people like my
brothers and i'll be like how's the
weather and they'll tell me
it's [__] terrible it was great all
weekend well we had the same
every [__] party got canceled the
biggest little league tournament of the
year got cancelled i mean [__]
everything well got pushed back till
today
and today looks like it's going to be
all right but the field is going to be
shitty it was coming down [__] like a
typhoon
saturday morning the party saturdays got
cancelled except for one kid's party
thank god and i went if you don't think
i went
i [__] went and enjoyed myself you
understand me i had the hat on
i was jumping up and down with the kids
because there was nothing else going on
it was raining now
saturday night you know i just relaxed
uh it's so [__] weird how
you have to catch yourself sometimes
sunday was a great day we were supposed
to go to joe florentines
that got [__] rained out that got
pushed the next weekend so next weekend
i got like 19 activities the girls
softball tournament starts thursday
[__] night
so yeah this is uh this weekend [__]
me up but you know what man
no matter what happened this weekend i
was in a great [__] mood the whole
weekend and i'm even in a better mood
today
and i'll tell you why january 4th
my drive my wife was driving me down the
brick
to do surgery on my knee and guys i
wasn't too happy
between you and me guys i would have
[__] made my wife
turn that car around but then i had to
face you guys and i'd have to tell you
how i pussied out
on the surgery because i was too scared
because of my [__] knee
and how would i look to you guys so i
put my chin up and i walked into that
hospital
and as scared as i was of coving as
scared of
as i was of needles as scared if i as i
was of everything
that had to do with it when they told me
to sit in a wheelchair you know they put
you in a wheelchair like a [__] jerk
off and they will you're like
i could walk the ladies like no you
gotta go in a wheelchair i gotta push
i'm
in that wheelchair saying to myself you
know what i'm going to be okay
i'm in good hands and this is all
going to be better by memorial day
if you look at any of my journals and if
i write you
read back to you any of my journals from
january 4th
i mean i even go back as november saying
that this will all be fine by memorial
day
i'm not nostradamus i'm not i'm not
saying in that
in that case it just so happened clover
died in new jersey on friday
that's it you don't have to wear a mask
no more people are now wearing masks and
businesses some people you know i bring
my mask out of respect i don't want to
piss anybody off
i don't want any [__] problems if i
see people don't have damascus then
i'll put my mask on but if somebody's
uncomfortable or whatever they come up
to me i put my mask
i'm not here to give anybody attitude or
anything in my world cove it's over in
your world
it should be over look at the [__]
sporting events they got people on top
of people
it's over nobody gives a [__] that's it
you got the president out that you
didn't like
you got your job completed okay now it's
over with so
i was i didn't even look at it like that
i didn't know about january 4th i knew
nothing
about a vaccine i knew nothing about
anything i just thought that for me
because the weather would break by that
time i would
uh you know be a little bit more settled
by that time the parts would have
clouded and the true color of the skies
would have shown
i would have known where i stood more
that's where i was coming from
and i am i'm very [__] happy uh
my stress levels have gone down a
thousand and one percent um
i don't have to take the anxiety
medication at all the last time i took
it was
doing the rudy sarzog uh guitar lesson
he [__]
stressed me the [__] out from a to z i
mean he's so intense
but everything else has been working out
i'm healthy i'm still losing weight i'm
still doing the weight watches
um you know my knee i got to tell you
something again
even when i went before the surgery and
i
was sitting there you know with the
[__] iv in my hand and [__] and i'm
like you know what
everything is gonna be better by late by
memorial day everything you know
and the last three days the biggest pain
i have throughout the day guys is not
walking
it's not um lifting
it's not riding the bike it's none of
the above you know what the
[__] hardest thing for me to do is
you know when i establish
pain as soon as i open my eyes and i
decide to get out of bed
i have to pull my hips up and turn
and go over and let my feet land on the
bed
and from my knee to my foot
my leg jiggles it feels like a loose
tooth do you have another loose tooth
and it goes
again you're like this [__] tooth is
gonna fall out any day
that's how my leg feels because of the
it muscle and the muscle that i tore
but i gotta tell you something the last
four or five days i haven't had it
so i think that that prediction i made
in my head about memorial day weekend
actually healed everything i mean i'm
okay knock on wood i'm not jumping up
and down i'm not gonna [__] go
and uh you know bungee jump or nothing
i'm still
[__] petrified uh you know it's like
a psychological thing guys i still
have to go to the corner yeah i still
feel that
my [__] knee is gonna fall off
when i'm [__] walking you know like
from time to time like
that's why i'm i'm so happy and we made
it on the reefer
we did 30 [__] days not a [__]
quitter but we did
30 [__] days and i'm gonna tell you
i was goofing on you guys last week and
telling you like you know
like i don't feel no differences i would
love
to be one of those jerk-offs you know
that walks to you with the water
and you know oh my god i'm never going
to smoke again
after my lungs i don't feel [__] i i
can't tell you but i thought i will tell
you what i
i did learn
let me take a quick sip of water here
you gotta hydrate or not things get bad
for you inside
i will tell you what i did learn that
i've been very very wrong on for the
last
30 years i've been talking [__] on this
podcast about it
you know i got when i talk about this i
gotta tell you the whole [__] deal if
not it's not gonna pan out
i got a very not hurtful and light
and lighting email about eight months
ago
it was somebody telling me about my drug
use
with the with the emphasis on marijuana
and they were explaining my situation
how
me doing what i was doing taking
pictures of pot and all that [__]
you know and it was a shitty uh email i
didn't really
put any weight on it but he was right in
some places
he made some valid points that i was
glamorizing marijuana
use you know that kids might be getting
it the wrong way and i
and i agree with that you know you guys
know i am in my house
right now i would love to [__] smoke
just to see
i'm doing a video of me smoking for the
first time do not think
that i am not going to do a video and
i'm going to roll a joint
show you the [__] percentage of it
and smoke the joint and see the results
and then after i say tremendous we're
going to cut that piece
and turn that into an nft if you don't
think i'm i'm going to do that for june
you got another thing coming but i will
tell you where i was wrong
with the the thc and the reefer
and i love marijuana i'm never gonna
bad-mouth it at all
i get pissed off when people tell me
that you know
they have different effects on marijuana
because i know they're bullshitting but
this effect
i know for a fact because it's been
affecting me the last
week and a half maybe two weeks my
dreams
started getting clearer you know not
alpha brain
dreams like there's alpha brain dreams
and then i had like a reefer dream the
last time i drank the michael jackson
tea
if you've noticed i haven't been
drinking the michael jackson tea
i still drink the kikomo tea i just
don't put all the [__] in there because
i had like a [__] very vivid dream
but yes it was funny when i was telling
the story
it was a dream about fidel chasing me on
a speedboat
and i was on a speedboat getting chased
but who
did i tell you was on that boat with me
my sister
i don't remember that so i actually went
to cuba in this dream
and got my sister
that's something that i've never really
thought of doing
since i was around eight i didn't think
about it when i had the dream
it was the dreams i started having a
couple of nights after that
they a very personal dream look
you ever watched like uh like one night
i was watching uh
a jared leto movie with denzel on hbo
max the new movie he made not a good
movie i
don't i don't remember what the [__] the
movie was about arson
or some [__] and
that night i had a dream that i was at a
party
and jared leto was there smoking pot
like it was like i don't remember
talking to him
i don't remember what music was on you
know i couldn't tell you a detail about
the dream
all i could tell you was the next day i
was going for a ride somewhere and i had
i said wow that was weird
i had a dream about jared leto because i
was watching his [__] movie
before i went to bed the night before
the reefer
with the [__] fidel chasing me on the
speedboat
yeah i was watching miami vice and tubbs
and crockett
were chasing some other guy on the
speedboat and the guy went off the
street
and maybe i took that to bed with me and
i had that dream about the speedboat but
where did my sister come from in this
stream
and the last couple of nights after that
not last night but i think friday night
i had a dream of me having a
conversation with my mother
like a full-on conversation with my
mother
uh i think wednesday night i actually
had a dream
where i actually and guys it's been
he's been dead for 55 [__] years
i don't know what he looks like anymore
i don't know i don't remember nothing
but i will tell you i had a dream that i
was actually talking to my father
my step my real father and i could see
him in the dream
and i could you know like i think i
cried or whatever
but i woke up i was fine you know it was
throughout the day that i'm like
i had a dream about manolo last night
when the [__] did this happen
so i'll tell you what that is i think
that the weed
was covering up some of my you know yeah
listen guys
when i was [__] 16 i ran into a
[__] brick wall of life
you know i needed everything i could to
shutter those [__] feelings down
so i could [__] you know move on with
my life
and obviously it was just putting them
in a [__] closet
and now all these dreams are coming out
of my [__] closet
and i gotta face the realities of my
[__] dreams or what's in my psyche
and i think that's what the weed helped
uh
are they nightmares not at all they're
not nightmares there's nothing bad
nothing i wake up it's just very
enlightening [__] dreams
and i kind of like to be honest with you
it's letting me know that
my mother's still in my life my father's
still my life
and my sister still in my life that's
something you know i weigh
very heavy my sister's life weighs very
[__] heavy on me
a lot i don't disclose a lot of it i
don't talk about it a lot i mean
it's something i should talk to a
psychiatrist about or something but
i never really got to that place but my
sister is something that
you know i can't talk to my sister as
much as i like calling her or whatever
you know our lines of communication were
open for years
and we were getting to a certain place
and i think that i uh
offered too much to her too quick
you know she kept wanting me to go to
cuba this is years ago three four years
ago
our connection really started again like
in 2013 when my daughter was born
i went out to you know
contact my sister and you know i talked
to my cousins
my cousins had come to the improv and we
went to canters and ate dinner and
you know spoke till five in the morning
and they filled me in on what was going
on
with my family in cuba and i said let me
make a conscious decision here
and throughout everything that was going
on touring podcasts you know specials
i was trying to put my sister together
you know like just trying to call her
and
talk to her and reach out and uh have a
relationship with her i got a family now
i wanted a relationship with my [__]
sister
so i went out of my way and called her
every week i'd have to go buy a special
[__] calling card and
it was like fifty dollars for eight
[__] minutes to talk to cuba i mean
it was a [__] nightmare
but i did it she's my sister and uh my
mother was dead
this is what i need to do to reopen up
this avenue
this was something i needed to do for me
i thought i was doing the right thing
but i gotta be honest every time i
[__] talk to her
when i get off the phone i had to smoke
[__] ten joints and drink [__]
teeth ten kamikazes
you guys know i don't drink kamikazes
and i'm but you understand what i'm
saying to you
the conversations were way that much on
my psyche
because it was all it would always end
up on you got to enjoy our mother and i
did and i'm like i
i wish you knew what you were talking
about
that there was a ton of suffering
involved here you know there was not
this was not a [__] trip to [__]
disney world
you know afterwards so but she doesn't
understand that
i kind of don't understand her world
so what i tried to do on my end was to
reach out to her to bring her here to
the states
since i was having such a hard time with
the passport thing
and i i offered to california i would
bring it back here
show her [__] the grave show where my
mother's bar was
where our you know business was located
in new york different
just to spend time with her and she told
me that she didn't want to come to the
united states you know that
she's a full-blown [__] commie
what am i gonna do i can't you know i
can't force somebody to do something i
don't want to do
so kind of in a way i took it as uh
an insult which i'm oversensitive i
should have never got
insulted over it so our conversations
have slowed down over the years we've
just been talking
during the holidays and like i called
her this year for her birthday and left
a message
you know it's march 19th um
if you ever call somebody and yeah you
you call them and you want to talk to
them
but you're kind of happy if they don't
answer the phone and you leave a message
and you're like woof
i got out of that [__] hot seat
that's how i feel now
you know so and i shouldn't feel that
way that's my [__] sister that's the
only blood i really [__] have in this
world
but just going back to the effects of
marijuana that's all i felt
to be honest with you guys i did
uh get a little agitated the other night
um i have not been agitated at all this
has not been like
a thing that i'm quitting anything you
know i don't believe
in diets like people always go don't
call them a diet and you won't get
pissed off
call them a change in lifestyle and
you'll be a lot better off if you just
go
i'm having a change in a lifestyle
change you'll be a lot better off and
that's the same thing i'm doing
here it's don't call it a comeback i've
been here for years anyway
uh i don't know man i just thought i'll
call jay there for a minute
uh you know i'm gonna smoke again i'm
sure i just i just wanted to give
everything a breather
and that's what the big notice that
i thought that reefer was recreational
or whatever
i think i was wrong i think that it uh
hit back some of my emotions and now i'm
enjoying them i'm enjoying
dealing with these emotions i do not
know
but i you know and the listen the dreams
aren't that vivid
where like my mother's coming to me and
she's saying
bet the knicks it's it's it's not that
it's not one of those dreams you know
she came to me in a dream they told me
to bet the knicks now
i'm done betting the [__] next by the
way listen i'm done betting the knicks
and the nets i learned the hard way this
[__] week
but i will tell you one thing guys i
love draftkings i love
i love gambling i don't like i didn't
like excessive gambling when i was a kid
growing up here
i did not like what my friends were
doing that style of gambling
this new style of gambling is kind of
[__] fun
you know and uh last monday night
my daughter had a softball game and i
was talking to dan florentine
and we were talking about the nba i
think you said you bet on that and
we were talking about
we were talking about uh
the nba just just stupid [__] you know
watching the girls swap pokemons a bunch
of guys and he was going
the thing about the playoffs i didn't
even know it was a [__] player
he goes the thing about the nba playoffs
is that they play defense
so that means you got to start looking
at totals instead of you know instead of
looking at games
you look at totals and again i was bored
monday night
so i think i bet two totals and i split
so i won one game and i lost the other
one no big [__] deal
25 you win like 19 if you win
i just do it just to in between tv shows
i go back and i
watched what the game i can't watch a
whole basketball game
and you just only the last three minutes
[__] counting you know
so i [__] split out monday night
tuesday night i think i bet oh no i push
sunday night with the next let's get
this straight
sunday night i push with the knicks
monday night i split
and then tuesday night i think i lost
so wednesday i actually called my man
the philly godfather
and this [__] gave me two
[__] winners
on wednesday night that were tremendous
and then thursday
i called the philly godfather again he's
[__] good
you see him on twitter posting all that
[__] and showing money
this guy is [__] good he gave me
another pic
thursday night and it [__] won i
got a little money back me you know i'm
[__] [__]
when i signed up for draftkings i signed
up for the fantasy instead
and i don't know what i'm doing with
fantasy so they asked me you know
do all these pools and [__] a dollar so
it's a [__] dollar you're not doing
nothing you might as well put a team
together
so i put a [__] team together and
they told me i was over budget i
i have no idea what i'm doing with
fantasy so i just put a team together i
bet a couple things i forgot all about
it
right i forgot all about this so i told
dan florentine
that i had all this money on my 600
bucks on my [__]
draftkings fantasy
and i don't know what i'm doing he's
like you got to get a [__] transfer
over to your sports book you [__]
idiot
so i had to call draftkings and you know
the customer service was great
the whole [__] thing but guess what i
actually hit one of the pools
i [__] once like 200 on one of the
pools
not knowing anything that's just to
prove to people
that you don't need to know [__] about
gambling house mothers do it and [__]
win money
but anyway i [__] hit with the philly
godfather on thursday night
and friday i was all fired up i'm like
there's going to be a bunch of [__]
games
i'm going to call the philly godfather
but friday night
friday day my daughter there was no
school down here you know
because they had a winter day left over
can you [__] believe that
there was no school for four months and
they had a winter day left over so they
made them take the day off to make it a
five-day weekend
so the girls went up to [__] in some zoo
and i was stuck down here all [__]
day so i had i had to go to the gym i
had some phone calls to make
you know i talked to erica on the book i
did a bunch of [__] [__]
and then my wife called him she's like
what are you doing for dinner i go i
don't know
what are you doing for dinner she's like
we're all going to christine's
you're on your [__] own so i was like
god damn i didn't give a [__]
i i went and got my [__] i got this
little place i go to
nice grilled chicken i got some nice
grilled chicken
i got some nice mac and cheese six
points and i got i ordered mashed
potatoes but the guy gave me broccoli
he couldn't hear [__] mashed potatoes
and broccoli was
through the mass so i didn't give a [__]
because the grilled chicken was [__]
zero points on weight watchers
so all i had was the mac and cheese six
points and then from there i went next
door
i wanted to give myself a treat because
i'm supposed to have 61 weight watcher
points
and i already had 74 and working out
with the walk-in therapy
so i went next door and i got myself a
nice little coconut milk
pliable [__] uh fruit bowl
because fruit is zero points and i don't
touch the [__]
uh milk the coconut milk with the with
the protein powder and the blended
bananas four points
and i have eliminate the granola so i
just eat the [__] fruit just to get
my stomach going
then my wife calls me and says christine
and them are ordering [__] pizzas
and sandwiches they want you to come
over so i actually went over there
and had a [__] great time but i
noticed something while i was over there
i kept looking at my clock and i'm like
i want to go home and play so [__]
better you know i wanted to call the
philly godfather
and place a better than i go
here we go here we go this is what we
were talking about last week catching
yourself
that sometimes we don't check ourselves
you know
i'm i've started to do this about 10
years ago and it's been working for me
i wish i would have started doing this
at 20. if i would have done this at 20
i would have been that guy from [__]
whatever right now
jumping out of planes i would have been
worth 80 billion [__] dollars
if you don't check yourself in this life
on a constant [__] level
that's when you start to slip and i was
starting to slip on friday
i kept looking at the clock going i'm
gonna get home
i want to call the philly godfather and
place a bet i think i liked
boston i liked atlanta
and i liked kwame leonard to do
under on his [__] game against the
dallas mavericks
that's what i liked i looked at it early
in the daytime
but here i am with kids here i am with
my wife
here i am with a family and i'm thinking
about [__] going in and putting three
25 dollar bets
whether it's 25 bets or it's 5 000
bets it's still [__] gambling and
it's something that's supposed to be fun
not supposed to be doing for me to do
remember
when you gamble once a week the odds of
you making money
are more than you gambling seven nights
a week remember that
when you go to the well seven times
especially with basketball that's every
[__] night you gotta be right
you know what i ended up making myself
worth 217 dollars
joey what's 217 you can't do nothing
with that that's fine
you know what i'll buy gas right gas is
three dollars a [__] gallon
even if i buy gas at 217 that's a lot of
[__] money where i come from
i don't give a [__] what anybody says
and that's what i was using it for
it wasn't for me to become that's the
problem i had when i was 19.
i was gambling to become a millionaire
me and my [__] friends
you're not gonna become a millionaire
you want to do it as fun
it's great i [__] encourage you but
see i even caught myself
and this is why i like this [__] this is
why i love journaling
this is why i'm looking at my goals from
[__] last year
i'm looking at my goals from two years
ago and i got to tell you something guys
i can't believe how much my goals have
changed
what i wanted two years ago is not what
i want
today everything two years ago had to do
with business
everything now has to do with me being
happy it's it's so weird to look at it
and to see the [__] jump you know i
have
a thousand things going on right now
without stand-up comedy
i am so happy to say this and this is
the life i wanted
i always loved doing stand-up comedy i
didn't want to dominate my [__]
life and if you leave it up to your
agents and everybody else that's what
they want for you to be out there
every [__] week until you die
you know one of the best things i ever
did was watch the elvis documentary on
hbo i still think it's on hbo max or if
you have hbo
app if you haven't watched the elvis
[__] documentary watch it
that elvis documentary was what
it didn't open up my eyes it confirmed
to me
what the other side thinks and if you
watch the [__] elvis documentary i
think it's a three-part documentary they
think
they did like a three-part sinatra
documentary maybe a two-part or a
three-part
part elvis documentary if you guys want
to fact check it and hit me back on
twitter and help everybody else watch it
watch it but if you're a comic it's
really important that you watch
what what elvis in this elvis
documentary
there was a part where towards the end
i mean i [__] love elvis i don't know
if you guys know this
i'm pissed at the united states that we
have
just forgotten about [__] elvis when
i was growing up elvis was on tv every
[__] night i loved jailhouse rock
but dawg i got an elvis album in there
live from hawaii aloha whatever the [__]
i [__] love elvis you can laugh at me
all you [__] want that [__]
if you're gonna be a good stand-up comic
and you don't study elvis
you you're [__] out of your mind
elvis is andrew dice clay
elvis is ralphie may i can name five
[__] comics that looked at elvis
and learned from elvis and i was one of
those guys i think elvis
the only problem with me and elvis was
elvis was beautiful i'm an ugly
[__]
elvis was [__] beautiful i saw a
[__] picture of elvis
about six months ago i had to call my
wife down and say
find me something more beautiful than
that and i'm not gay
i know beauty though when i [__] see
it he was [__] beautiful
and he could that [__] could
rock when he wanted to rock yeah
a lot of his [__] was you know but
elvis taught me [__] a lot about
performing i
still watch elvis dawg i i'm a jailhouse
rock [__]
the same way i'm a plane trains and
automobiles type of [__]
i learned more about body movement from
jailhouse rock from elvis
than i did from comedy from john candy
and [__]
steve martin and playing trains and
automobiles if you got a problem with
all this
you watch jailhouse rock and you go get
back to me that [__]
drops around there but anyway to get
back to the [__] documentary
before i get fired up on elvis here
elvis there's a part towards the end i
don't know if you guys know anything
about elvis i've read like 20 books
the colonel i forget what his real name
was was like elvis
[__] father he was his manager
he was a mentor he [__] made all this
elvis
he was a great [__] manager but they
caught him on tape
towards the end saying that
you know when elvis is dressing up with
the [__] belt
and he was fatter than i was in the
longest yard he was throwing karate
kicks
you know you knew his time was coming
like
he looked at all this and you're like
[__] fat elvis is killing me but i was
holding on for dear life
let me tell you something in 75 when i
was [__] 12 i got into an argument
about elvis i was holding on to dear
life to elvis
elvis died when i was 14. i'll just die
like in august
when i was at superstar basketball camp
and i got to tell you something i cried
a little bit on the bus
when i always died when i when i saw it
in the paper i didn't know he died
taking his [__] or whatever
but none of this [__] really [__]
matters
the point is [__] elvis was a bad
[__] and at the end
they catch his they have tape audio tape
of his manager the colonel who loved and
adored him
telling a promoter listen man elvis is
damaged goods
what we're gonna do is this we're gonna
put him on the road
and put him out there until he dies
we're gonna squeeze
every last penny out of him when i heard
that audio tape
my [__] heart broke right there on
that couch like my [__] heart just
broke
because it confirmed what i always knew
about booking agents and
people in the entertainment business
they blow smoke up your ass and they
just put you out there
until you die get busted or get shot or
get put in prison
you know if you ever watch the thief at
the end when he hits james cahn in the
head
and he tells the guy you're going to
work for me till you're [__] burnt
out
dead or in the [__] joint and when
that reality comes to you in life it's a
[__] reality that's
it that's how you're going to [__]
end up so when i [__] heard that
i was like okay i got to check myself
now i don't want to end up on the road
and i don't want to give these guys the
control
to think that much about me money is not
worth me being away from my family that
[__] much
if elvis if ralphie if all these
comments
if you could bring them back richard
pryor paul mooney who's got kids and go
was it [__] really worth it
if you could do it all over again would
you find a healthier balance
they would say yes i have a lot of
things going on right now
you know i'm i'm trying to write a great
book for you guys with erica florentine
i mean
we are working [__] hard on this this
is not gonna be an
easy i don't want you guys to think that
we're just throwing things together here
we're focusing on the things that i have
never told you over the years
the things that were going on inside of
me in my head in my heart
this is not just some book about me
stealing and doing [__] drugs
i'm taking you guys to the next level i
want to do this
for what you guys have done for me i
wanted to tell you so i'm working on
that
i'm working on the nfts i'm trying to
put a podcast together
we're trying to get a new studio going
and uh start a new podcast there
i mean my hands are [__] full i'm
trying to raise a daughter
i got [__] softball practice now they
just added more games
more tournaments all stars i mean my
[__]
you know my [__] i'm thin here you
know
i'm thin because i want to take the
summer off and i want to enjoy it listen
to be a good comic to tell you a good
story i have to go out
and find new stories and do new things
you know i've even gotten into new
friends like i
i went out to dinner thursday night with
my neighbor he's my friend now
frankie we you know we went to the
[__] brass rail
and got a tremendous pot roast [__]
sandwich you know
i mean uh i had the fried diablo because
i had already had meat in the daytime
i don't like eating that much meat i had
the seafood far diablo
nothing else i didn't put no i didn't
eat no bread no butter on the bread
nothing but you know i'm trying to
change everything
you know i just didn't want to have
comedy friends anymore
that was my problem in l.a everybody i
had was a comedy friend
or somebody associated with the business
in some sort of way
i'm trying to make friends with normal
people with dads
i'm friends with a guy that's a retired
nine you know he got hurt during 9 11.
i'm hanging out with a [__] newark
detective i'm hanging out with a guy
that's in charge of sanitation in new
york
i'm hanging out with people that are
giving me a different perspective you
know what i'm saying it's not the same
[__] perspective that i was living
with in california you know
something happened on the way to dance
yesterday uh yesterday friday
that really uh showed me how far i've
come
as as a human being even since i've been
here
i told you that what i hated the most of
what what i was living through
the last five or six years
was the desperation i didn't like that
feeling
it was desperate all around me i felt it
again last thursday
when i flew to l.a i felt that
desperation in the air
i feel like the other shoe is going to
drop i can't believe a friend of mine
said
the other shoe you felt was going to be
an earthquake and i looked at them weird
i'm like don't even
please but anyway um
you know i felt that desperation that i
didn't like anymore i didn't accept it
and i didn't want it in my house not
only am i writing a book
not only am i you know trying to do all
these [__] things
i'm also trying to put together a tv
show in conjunction with the book
with a complete different writer
he is a great guy this writer is a great
guy
i met him by taking his class
i took his writing class it was like an
eight-week
class on a script and you know what he
taught me a lot of [__] about
scriptwriting
did i end up writing a script no but at
least i got an idea
and it's going to be the next book for
me and erica me and eric are going to
start a corporation
and we're just going to write books
she's got ideas
i've got ideas and together you know two
heads are better than one
you know we're friends we're gonna be
business partners
so we already have an idea for the next
book
you know you want me to tell you it
let's listen to this one
the other day i was talking to my
[__] daughter at the
softball field we were doing something i
don't know who was just sitting there
and she was talking to me about what she
learned in [__] school or something
about animals and all the animals that
were down here
i said to her would you ever think about
what's in those [__] trees
and she started telling me all this [__]
about what lives back there and what
animal she likes i'm sitting there going
this kid knows a lot more than what i
[__] thought
so all of a sudden she goes that's why i
think when i graduate high school i
think i'm going to move to colorado like
you did and i'm like
you're going to move to colorado oh my
god what makes you say that
i'm you know i'm just bullshitting with
her trying to talk to her you know
having a conversation with and she's
like well dad
you went there and they have all these
animals and all this stuff
because i was talking about about
independence past one day
we were talking about if we go to aspen
next year i'm going to take i want to go
in the summer
because i want to take them over
independence pass independence pass
is only open from july to like the
second week of september
it's only open three [__] months a
year and it's a cliff
it's basically a [__] road that's a
road and a half and if you
[__] take too far of a thing
you be if your car doesn't have
wings it's night night i have gone
through independence past
with people who have murdered people and
they have cried the whole way like you
i'll never do this again
i'll [__] kill you and at the end the
independence pass there used to be a
place called the black wolf inn or
something
and you could stay the night there
because it's a pretty [__] exhausting
drive once you make it you you you what
do you call white knuckle it
the whole [__] way because if you
make one wrong move you go off that
[__] cliff
so it's called like the black wolf and
it used to be there when i was a kid
and you would just spend the night there
and eat and then at night the wolves
would howl
at midnight you're like in your bed this
is tremendous it wasn't [__]
tremendous
you know so it was tremendous it was
beautiful it was nature i was young
it takes an hour off the trip between
aspen to denver so if you're ever going
from aspen to denver
and it's july through september take
independence pass
bring a camera take pictures and you
take an hour off what did this have to
do with what we were [__] talking
about joey okay
so my wife when my daughter told me she
wanted to go to colorado
you know we're talking i said to her
wouldn't this be weird
if i [__] died you know like when she
turns
70. like when she turns 23 or something
i'm 73 i die right
she goes to colorado and i
wouldn't just be a great script and she
bumps into my
other daughter and they don't know like
they work together or something
they don't know and one of them oh your
last name is diaz oh my god and
what would happen like what would happen
so i [__] ran right downstairs and
started [__] writing scenarios
and it was great that's the creative
channel at least for getting somewhere
doesn't matter what you write as long as
you're writing whether it's comedy drama
a [__] song trust me i can't write a
song to save my [__] night
i admire those songwriters but um
that was what was you know going on like
i was like
jesus christ so this is what's going on
i have i have other things i want to
really [__] do with
with writing you know i've always been a
fan of books
i've always read authors and jerked off
all over myself you know stephen
spielberg when i read his books you know
stephen king that
you know i've jerked off all over myself
i mean you know i i look up to authors
like [__] you the holy [__] grail
and i'm just horrible at it but i've
continued to work on it but anyway
i teamed up with this guy this guy is a
great guy he's a great writer
he's not a name writer and this is the
problem you have everybody needs a name
well so what as long as they're a good
[__] writer
you know what i'm saying the guy's a
great writer so what if he hasn't
written the show how do you write a
great show by [__]
taking a chance on a writer and that's
what i did the guy's a great guy
we have great conversations he wrote a
tremendous pilot
you know we sent it to my agency but
since everybody's running scared and
they're trying to make money off the
the lowest branch which is [__] uh
the road since i'm not going on the road
and because they're scared that i
you know because i got in trouble last
year you know online which i didn't do
[__] it was a [__]
23 year old story everybody's scared all
of a sudden to pitch a tv [__] show
so i kind of got it i understand where
you're coming from you know
you don't want to pitch the tv show but
this guy is a great guy
at least let's try to help him so for
the last month
i've been telling the guy listen i think
you're putting too much weight on my
agency
let's go to your agency and let's do it
that way
i'm just trying to give the guy listen i
feel bad for the guy because we're not
getting any help
and in my mind i felt like i lied to the
guy i told him that my agent
would be [__] more than happy to sell
this show to him
he went out of his way and wrote this
[__] beautiful [__] pilot and now
we're getting no results from my agency
you know
and i knew this was gonna happen but i'm
not this upset about it
i you know i could pick up the phone and
yell and threaten and
you know please do this or call or i'll
leave you to go to another agent
i'm to the point in my life i don't want
to go to another age
i got a guy in new york that's helping
me for new york auditions that's why
i've been
i put another audition down last week
for a tv show
you know i got a guy over there i don't
know what i want to do about the road
yet that's all going to be organic it's
not going to be pushed
you know i got the soprano movie coming
i just got a call we got to take
pictures or something
you know i have stuff going on
but i feel bad for this rider because
he's really busted his hump
doing this so we try to talk twice a
week you know we made notes on the pilot
they wanted him to go a different
direction with the pilot and blow up my
mom
they were like let's take the heat off
joey and let's blow up his mom because
times are changing they're looking for
shows
with strong women now what's better than
a strong ethnic woman
any coincidence why they made the
equalizer an african-american woman
okay then they want to make women strong
and ethnic women
so we'll take the joey dear story and
make it about his mother
we had it going he wrote a tremendous
[__] treatment the whole thing
he's not getting any response you know
there was people at my agency that i
used to email just to say hello
and they would email me back you know
just to check in what i [__] preach
i [__] hit them up when the pilot i
sent them all pilots
all of a sudden they stopped talking to
me you know what i could sit here
and be upset but i wasn't it's not my
world anymore
so i'm talking to him on friday and
i in fact i even got up
text him and said listen i'm going to
talk to you i want i want to talk to you
and lay it out for you
i went to a park got out of the [__]
car was such a beautiful day out [__]
friday before the rain came
and i walked i walked like a mile just
explaining to him
what the situation was and what we have
to do like we have no love coming
from my agents this is a reality
this is a reality you know like we got
no love coming from this guy
after i explained myself for 40 [__]
minutes
i walked back to my car to get something
to drink i'm [__] thirsty
i'm still talking to him i get in the
car
and i go to him so listen reach out to
your people
and we'll take it from there i'm sorry
my people are not reacting in other
words i was giving him a way out like
listen guy
this isn't working you know
i've been telling i've been getting
calls from agents and managers
since january and i've told them all the
same they want to sign me they want to
talk to me
i go look wait till this is all over
wait till the piece is settled
let's see who's let's see who the last
man standing is let's see who's still
going to be standing
and then we'll make up our [__] minds
but in reality i i'm just trying to just
to figure out everything
of where i want to go and what my next
move is i have an idea
i have an idea and i have a plan that's
going to work
but this tv thing obviously doesn't look
like it's working you know you
you have to have 20 ideas for two of
them to work
you're not just going to go at me with
one idea
this is going to work they're gonna if
it doesn't work you need it you know
so with me i had like the nfps the tv
show
i got the mugs coming by the way the
mugs got pushed back again
yes the [__] friday the reason why i
had to stay home was from one to three
because we were going to get the mug
delivery and i'm [__] i sat here my
wife calls me
i've been here for [__] all day the
mugs didn't come she goes no we just got
an email
the [__] mugs got pushed back to like
june 15th
so i'm sorry if you're waiting for mugs
i'll get them to you before the end of
the [__] month
anyway so i just pitched this guy 40
minutes on why we should just give this
a breather
or he should take this to his people i
go we got nothing going on here
there's nothing here do you know what
this guy said to me at the end of the
conversation
he goes i think i'm gonna
i go just move on with it and take it to
your people or find somebody else
and if i find somebody i'll do the same
but what we're beating ourselves up and
this is i saw people doing this in l.a
constantly this was something i would do
yeah 97 98 99 when i first got there
but i haven't lived by that i'm the type
of guy that
knows no move on what are you doing
what are you doing they're not going to
help you
they don't want to help us what the [__]
can you do
so he says do i go to him so just take
it to your guy okay
who's marky wahlberg's guy that
that's a legit guy that guy can help you
i get in the [__] car he says to me
can i tell you one thing he goes i think
i'm gonna reach out one more time to caa
so right away i'm like
what did we just [__] talk about i
know what the [__] that we just talked
about for the last hour i i just
and then he says to me and i have two
other questions for you
and i go what and he goes
what character do you see yourself
playing and i go
none i don't want to be involved in this
i just want to be a co-creator and get a
check once a week i don't want to be
behind the camera
i don't want to be on the set with those
[__] pedos all [__] day
i just don't want to [__] do it i
just don't want to [__] do it
and then i thought you know after
somebody says that to you
you're like okay obviously this guy he
says to me
who do you see playing your mom
and i'm like brother if we can't get an
agent on the phone
who do you see playing my mom i so
i got off the phone with him and i did a
bunch of stuff and i went out with my
wife and
then the whole weekend you know saturday
i wake up to [__] four
canceled parties except for one kid
party
but that's not the point of the story
the point of the story was i thought was
that's the desperation that i wanted to
get away from
who have you thought to play your mom
these are the steps that i whenever i
would have
meetings with people and they would go
up
like let's keep it to step one
let's get it pitched first let's get
dates to pitch it first
you know let's get a date with abc nbc
fox
netflix cbs you know hulu
and then in that room
you decide but until then while we get
i remember going to a meeting with a guy
about an animated show
and he was already talking about stuffed
toys to sell
we haven't even pitched a [__] show
we don't even know where the show is
and he already contacted people for
[__] stuffed toys to sell stuff
toys and i'm like this is what's called
desperation
a desperation that i didn't mind leaving
a desperation that i left behind years
ago
and all that desperation that i needed
to get out of
because this is what it does to your
[__] mind who do you see
playing your mom are you [__]
[__] you can't even get a guy on the
[__] phone
why would i even think of why would i
mind [__] myself like that
and this is what i'm talking about mind
[__] mind [__]
will take you down quicker than [__]
drugs
gambling alcoholism don't let yourself
get mind [__] especially if you're in
the business
don't think of plans z
let's just worry about [__] plan a
and that's it that's the [__]
memorial day
podcast i'm happy you [__]
listen i'm gonna go out now and find
myself a few barbecues
and go enjoy my day and get this week
going off on the right foot
i don't want you to think because i'm
not smoking lately that i'm not dosing
[__] i had a great week last
week dosing a few [__]
i had to dose my nephew i went up to uh
to north bergen listen i go up to north
bergen
very rarely but when i do go up there i
have a great time you know i hate the
traffic up there
and i hate driving along all the way you
know i never drive past 76th street
i always stick up north i never you know
i
this week i actually stopped at the
[__] cemetery and got spooked again
i didn't bring any flowers i just
brought one of these little [__]
candles i have
and a little candle for her and i looked
for that [__] lawnmower guy
and i couldn't find that [__] sucker on
wednesday i'm gonna find him
i gave him a [__] yardstick and he
didn't ever cut my mother's lawn that
[__] [__] sorry people i get so
[__] pissed at him
how dare you and then i went up to [__]
and uh see my
nephew nick i had to drop some edibles
on him
he dropped the [__] an edible on mikey
chick and he dropped an edible
on my man tony from roses let me tell
you something
rose's delicatessen in north bergen is
so
[__] good because of my weight
watches and my [__] uh you know
little [__]
uh point system i you know i like last
time i was like
when i first went up there he's got some
sausage and pepper empanadas
that'll push on a different [__]
planet you understand me
he's got a [__] italian sandwich like
a project salami
on wet mozzarella with the bread that'll
make you [__] salivate like a [__]
momo you understand that's how good
he's got wise potato chips he's got all
this [__]
that'll [__] kill me that i [__]
love you know i grew up at hashways so i
never went to rose
now hashtags is dead and i don't feel so
good myself
roses is on [__] fire so i went up
there i saw one of my brothers i had him
meet me there
i wanted to give him a little [__]
reefer and a couple edibles
and i gave my nephew the heavy duty abx
i gave him like three and i think like
three or four and he gave him a round to
mikey chick and tony and [__] like that
but when i was sitting there i was
looking at the [__] menu
do you know they have a roast beef with
wet mozzarella
with [__] gravy that my brother was
eating
that i felt like grabbing his hand and
eating the whole sandwich
and his [__] hand it looks so [__]
good but i know that
between the cheese i'll be constipated
and the [__]
you know sitting there i'll be [__] i
can't eat that [__] because i'm so
[__] guilty
i'm such a half a [__] fruitcake
anymore that
but i just want to let you guys know i'm
not a half a fruitcake
i'm still dosing [__] with
three hands you understand me
my nephew called me that night telling
me that [__]
he had to call his a friend of his to
pick him up at the mall
because he couldn't drive home i'm like
i did my job
i made my may this day i love you
[__] have a great day
have a happy memorial day i'm sorry if
the weekend was shitty my weekend
was not shitty i just hey it was [__]
rain
that's it who gives a [__] covert is
over
you were free to go out you were free to
[__] barbecue with an umbrella
you know it was all up to you it's so
crazy
covert is like [__] when i was in the
halfway house
when i went to the [__] uh it's the
truth man
i hear that one let me tell you what
happened there's restaurants all around
here and there's restaurants half hours
from here and i was mad
i told you about that restaurant it's
like a half hour from my house
i love it it's called the [__] uh
doesn't matter they have the [__]
they have the the prime rib sandwich
there
so i'm always scared when i go there
because one time i went there like in
[__] january
and there was a line out the door and
covered and then it was [__]
40 degrees hot whatever the [__] it's
called
it's great the prime rib sandwich is
great
so when i got my covert shot i went
there and treated myself to the [__]
me and my buddy went there
and got the the brass rail and got the
prime rib sandwich oh with a little
horseradish cream on it
oh when you get yourself a baked potato
with no f or
you just get the salad i get the salad
but it's tremendous either way
so every time i somebody invites me
there i'm always scared because
it's gonna be [__] packed so
i went when i went there with my man
frankie and i was thursday night
me having this kid when it was the boys
night out
and then his wife his daughter my wife
and my daughter went to a different
restaurant and they had pizza and [__]
like that
but when i got there i had a mask on and
the owner looked at me and he goes
do me a favor i go what he goes take
that [__] thing off
i go thank you i go [__] he goes covert
is dead in jersey
i go i thought it was friday morning it
was nah i just decided it was tonight
i go okay so i sat down i had my little
prime ribs i had my little
[__] fried diablo and uh
as i'm walking out he goes how was
everything i go was pretty good thank
you for always
and i go hey man how come this [__]
place
isn't packed right now it's 90 degrees
the sun is out i go your [__]
balcony is empty what the [__] is going
on here and he's like you know
last thursday you couldn't even fart in
here
he goes it was packed walled the wall i
had to throw people out
i couldn't let him sit you know people
wanted he goes i even had people that
came with outside drinking because i was
scared i was gonna get in trouble
but he goes now that they lifted the
bait you know when it's like
we're kids when we get punished we need
to get out we need to get out
now that we lift the ban nobody wants to
go out oh just eat at home so it was so
weird coverts like the halfway house
when i was in the halfway house i wasn't
allowed to do coconuts all i
ever wanted to [__] do right you're
not allowed to do drugs
all day you're walking around like i
can't wait to do drugs i can't wait to
do drugs
once they restrict that once they lifted
that i didn't walk around and want to do
drugs anymore
so it's the same [__] thing with our
mind with covet like they didn't let us
out now they're letting us out we're
like
i'll [__] pass anyway i love you
[__] have a great week
uh it's a beautiful day to be alive
enjoy the rest of your memorial day
hopefully you guys didn't get rained on
your beautiful week
and no matter what it was a great
weekend
and it's gonna be an even better week
have a great week i love you [__]
thank you for all the support
and uh we'll see you [__] wednesday
we'll see you in june [__]
love you to stay black and now for a
word
for my [__] sponsors all right
you dirty [__] i want to thank
you
for being a part of memorial day i was
gonna do a whole [__]
you know uh memorial day thing don't
worry the day is still young
i might surprise you today so keep your
eyes open on instagram and all that [__]
i gotta get a little [__] navy suit
and give you a little [__] attention
and a little national anthem but
before i go i want to give a word out to
our beautiful sponsors listen
the joint is brought to you by blue chew
blue chew is tremendous okay
blue chew is an online service that
delivers the same active ingredients
as viagra and cialis at a fraction of a
price
the process is simple you sign up at
bluetooth.com
you speak to one of the licensed medical
providers
and bing bang boom once you're approved
you receive your prescription within
days
the good thing about blue chew is you
could take it any time
day or night just chomp on it you're
gonna love it
the best part is it's all online no
visits to the doctor
no awkward conversations you don't have
to [__] get brow beat by the doctor
and you don't have to go to the pharmacy
and wait online
and then they know about your [__]
problems and pharmacists are always
women
so they give you that [__] look like
your [__] weak sack of [__]
no no no no no more go to bluechew.com
right now
use promo code joey and i'm gonna hook
you up this month
it ships right to your door in a
discreet package
and the mailman don't know dick
bluetooth tablets are made in the u
s of a they're prepared and shipped
directly to your
door and it's way cheaper than the
pharmacy
and the doctor and all that [__] if
you could benefit from extra confidence
when it's time to sling dick blue chew
can help
we have a special going for you this
week all right this right now what this
week
i'm gonna give you a blue chew for free
joey what are you talking about free
free free free when you use promo code
joey at checkout i'm just gonna let make
you pay
five bucks for shipping what the [__]
beggars can't be choosy
you gotta pay for something [__]
that's bluechu.com
promo code joey to receive your first
month
free and as always i want to thank
bluetooth for sponsoring the joint but
let me tell you something
they're phenomenal from time to time
uncle joey's 58
i got to give mama a stabbing and i take
a little blue chew
i wait 30 seconds and next thing you
know i'm like john claude van damme in
there not really
i'm just telling you this to make
yourself look better but i love blue
chew so
give it a shot go to bluetooth.com right
now and use promo code
joey the joint is also brought to you by
magnesium breakthrough you guys know
i have a hard time with sleep i have not
been and i
can't take [__] crazy [__] because i
got sleep apnea so i gotta watch what i
take
somebody turned me on my agent fanny
turned me on to magnesium breakthrough
and it has changed my life and now
they're part of the show
and i'm happy i could bring it to you
i've tried everything from teas
to michael jackson dust but the one
thing that remains a constant in my life
is magnesium
magnesium breakthrough is taking me deep
into murky waters of dreamland
like i talked about on the podcast now
with the no reefer or whatever now i'm
really
sleeping to what i should be that's why
i'm looking better
that's why i'm losing weight magnesium
is a tremendous mineral
not only does it help you sleep it
reduces stress
it helps maintain a regular heartbeat it
boosts your immunity
and most importantly it lowers cortisol
that [__] that is the worst that's
when you start getting that big fat ball
behind your neck
i don't need that [__] most people are
magnesium deficient
and that's not good either you can't eat
enough [__] spinach
magnesium breakthrough works fast just
pop two capsules
before you go to bed in 30 minutes
you'll be sleeping like a [__] baby
i sleep better and i wake up feeling
tip-top magu every day
plus i'm more relaxed and i'm at peace
during the day this is what you guys are
seeing
this is magnesium breakthrough it's a
full spectrum
it's the only organic supplement that
includes seven
unique forms of magnesium quality
magnesium is key
most magnesium supplements only use two
cheapest synthetic forms
not magnesium breakthrough i'm still
recovering from knee surgery
and aside from the pt and eating right
the best thing i could do to heal and to
get strong
is to sleep when the body needs to and
that's what we're doing
with magnesium breakthrough sleep right
to avoid disease
and to lose weight do me a favor don't
sleep on this offer
right now for the joint family go to
magbreakthrough.com
show you again mag m-a-g breakthrough
break and through one word dot-com
slash joey use joey tender and check out
to save 10 percent okay again
magbreakthrough.com
use codejoey10 to save 10
and tell him uncle joey sent you and
tell the sandman to suck your dick
i love you [__] with all my
heart
i want to thank magnesium breakthrough i
want to thank bluechew.com
but i also want to thank you guys for
supporting and having my back
have a great memorial day i salute you
[__] with all my heart
and i'll see you guys wednesday tip top
[__] magoo stay black
there you go [__] have a great
[Music]
day
foreign
[Music]